so all the stuff I do now with players I
did with him when you got a dog you
agitate him he he doesn't respond to
nice he responds like this my I knew it
it ate him up aive but that was my
tactic to keep him going got to kill a
pit bull you don't pet him you piss him
off and make sure he stays that pit bull
so if it worked for him he shooting too
much doing this this ain't your team
this my like it's just to cuz I need him
just just to keep him going and it
worked remember you know Kobe wasn't
always Kobe like when he came in he was
a young guy and he had to be molded so
those first three years carry my backs
you ain't going to be like it it just
drove him
crazy and he wanted to be great he
wanted to be better than me he wanted to
be better than Mike and it just kept
going what I love about the most is 100
out of 100 times coob I need 40 boom
like last game I we was messing around I
said coob I need 50 went out and got 60
I egged him on to where the point he was
so pissed off at me but it worked out in
everybody's
favor